i think the biggest misconception about
people that are tattooed or about
getting tattooed
um is that you know it has this stigma
and people
you know think that people just want to
look badass
[Music]
laura shack thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders a good
morning to you good noon
yeah it's good afternoon over here good
afternoon to you good night to me
and that's what i love about uh you know
quran times have
have been very very timing for a lot but
but
this this getting to adapt to all these
different time zones it's been a pretty
pretty fun especially in a show like
this
thank you for joining me i'm incredibly
excited to talk about tattoos
of anything tattoos and laura are you a
tattoo artist
besides being a tattoo entrepreneur so
i'm actually not a tattoo
artist um and i think that's what has
been the detriment of a lot of people
that have attempted
something in the tattoo and tech space
the majority of founders have been
tattoo artists who decide you know maybe
i want to build an ad
i'm coming from a different angle right
so i've been working in tech for the
last 10 years
you know so like tech is my trade text
where i know building apps is what i
know
um and i love tattooing and i'm super
heavily tattooed and i have a lot of
tattoo artist friends here in new york
um so i'm definitely coming in at it
with a tech
lens and you know the learning curve is
really the artistry side
um but it's a really interesting you
know topic to have as a learning curve
so what does that mean when you say
heavily tattooed give me give me the the
details of it
i'm heavily tattooed um i mean i have a
full sleeve on my arm
i have you know a couple sort of random
ones here and there
um i have about half my left leg done
i have a good amount i love that so so
before we get into the tattoo space who
who are you laura give me the give me
the rundown of how you got to be a
tattoo entrepreneur in tech
and and we'll dive into that
intersection a little bit later but i
want to learn a little bit more about
you right now
yeah so um i kind of happened upon the
tech scene right and it happened i think
before
it got really really popular and then
silicon valley came out
and now every gen z or one just wants to
be a founder and be their own boss and
that's really cool
um but there's a lot more to it than
that right it's also really hard
um it's also a lot of pressure it's all
the stress um a lot of constant work
um so it really wasn't romanticized for
me honestly um
i was working in a sort of international
non-profit space actually
um and i needed something more
fast-paced right this is i
came here to new york when i was 17.
went to nyu
got out started working the nonprofit
space and was like this is great and i
love that i'm making an impact
um but it's not enough of an impact for
me right so i need a type of industry
that is super fast-paced that is going a
mile a minute that is ready to
um try really innovative really risky
things to see if that's the optimal way
of doing things um
that that probably only describes the
startup industry to be honest with you
um so i sort of accidentally uh moved
into the startup space um
i was one of the first employees at an
incubator that moved
european sas companies and integrated
them into the us market
um i lived abroad i had worked in madrid
spain for a while
um so i think these these european
entrepreneurs were sort of like
great she's european experience and also
she's only american on the team we need
we need a little both on the team so
they sort of took a chance i
i sat there and i took this job at what
23 or 4.
um but i thought i was just going to
travel to europe like those that's what
i thought i was doing
i didn't know at the time that i was
kind of entering the early stage tech
startup space
um you know little did i know fast
forward not even six months and i'm
going to
pitch competent competitions and you
know i'm talking about go to market
strategy and talking about product
market fit
um liaisoning with ceos and ctos from
europe um
way but way earlier than i probably
should have in my professional career
um it sort of went on to
really be really well integrated into
the startup scene here in new york right
so
um also joined some startups to build
them from the very ground
up um went through a number of
accelerator programs here in new york
uh i'm in here for one now actually um
and i think and then you know a little
bit after that also worked out some app
development firms
so definitely have a thorough
understanding of the tech side of things
so
the idea for tatted came about much
um further along than than whenever i
started it right i've had this idea for
almost five years
um i only started it about a year ago
because you know i came to the point
where i was like okay first of all
it took it took me a little bit of time
to become brave enough to do it right
like
i had seen founders i'd seen the really
ugly side like really scary
side the really intense side like i work
for the startups that aren't like
the twitters of the world where you just
get free snacks all the time like that's
not
but you know like some people i'll be in
networking events and people are like
oh yeah i worked i worked in the startup
industry too and i'm like but but which
type
like i went to the type where you're
unpaid working out of a founder's
apartment building
okay like that's not we've had different
experiences
you know what do you mean um but uh i
finally
came to a point in my career i was like
okay i've had sort of this trifecta of
experience right um
i have worked in incubators where i'm
seeing uh companies at scale right so
those sas companies were moving over
are like series a series b level seven
eight years old
like really ready to scale right have a
lot of capital behind them um i've seen
things
launched with very little to no money
from the very ground up
and i finally have after working at some
app development firms um a thorough
understanding of the technology side of
things right so i feel like i had sort
of this
you know sort of trifecta experience
that would allow me to start tatted
um and make it really really successful
even though i've had this idea for a
long time
so you know hopefully hopefully that's
what i'm doing that's that's that's
amazing so
so let's go back just a little bit uh
you know in the intersection of you you
have this idea for tattered for about
five years
and we're talking about the tattoo
market and we're talking about a
marketplace
that matches tattoo artists with people
that are looking
for their artists and so talk to me a
little bit about the market because i
really know nothing
about the tattoo industry and i've been
thinking and if my mom and my dad
and my girlfriend listen to this then
i'm in trouble but but you know
i've been interested to to understand
what what is the tattoo market why are
people getting tattoos what is the
benefit
or what what does it do to them you know
emotionally or or
psychologically so so please teach me a
little bit about about what's happening
there
absolutely so i think the biggest
misconception about people that are
tattooed or about getting tattooed
um is that you know it has this stigma
and people you know think that people
just want to look badass
um and everyone has that story of like
their drunk sorority sister that got
some horrible tattoo
or um whatever the kids may be and you
know
we all smoke a lot of cigarettes and
like maybe ride motorcycles and like
probably will
curse at you in a coffee shop line you
know what i mean like this is like the
idea of people that are tattooed
and it is so inaccurate and i need like
mainstream media
um to like stop making that portrayal i
don't need people to open their eyes to
you know the actual community of people
that are tattooed um tattooing is an
art um so funnily enough half my
coursework at nyu
was art history whenever i was like a
child
um i volunteered very young as early as
i could get a job at
the um art museum i grew up in austin
texas in austin
um like i like i thoroughly have an
understanding of fine art and
tattooing is an art right um these
people are usually
like illustrators or painters and sort
of common tattooing
um so tattooing is really significant to
the two artists but also about the times
to the person getting a tattoo right
um people get tattoos out of um sort of
like a memoriam of
of people that have passed um people get
tattooing because it makes them
feel empowered about their body you know
what you mean um
it's really closely aligned with their
identity and is something that is really
special to people and you know
is it's a way to express themselves
right it's not something that people
you know go and say like right now i
feel really cool and like people can't
talk to me anymore like
like that's not it at all you know it's
actually something really special um
you know and i think um millennials are
really kind of getting
a hold of that um you know millennials
and gen z
i mean people can say say a lot about
them but they they really do
push boundaries and they really do um
sort of defy the status quo
um and i think that's really benefited
the tattooing industry right um whether
you know they're no longer pulling away
from that stigma people are leaning into
it um
there's also a trend within the you know
that sort of mentality
uh that is sort of like a personal brand
customization
you know what i mean and it's my
question of you know
who am i and how do i differentiate when
i remember growing up it was all about
fitting in
you know so like i think and i think i
was sort of just on the cusp of that
change so it's really interesting for
someone um
my age i'm 29 you know if anyone
wondered but um
you know i think it's interesting for
some advice that saw what it was like
that
you know the mental was to fit in right
and become homogeneous
um and now i have seen a huge shift and
the mental is absolutely not that if
anything it's the antithesis of that
it's more like
you know who am i and like do
do i fit in with these people or do i
not and what does my individuality mean
and how
do i express or define the individuality
um and so i think that also sort of
spurring more and more and i mean the
numbers definitely show that industry is
increasing but you know i think
so give me a little bit about the
numbers of the industry how do we know
how many
tattoo artists out are out there what is
the demand for it how many p how many
tattoos are being administered on an
annual basis and stuff like that
yeah we um know that there's 145 million
americans that are tattooed which is
just about
wait wait wait wait wait half of
americans
are tattooed that's right what
that sounds crazy that's an incredibly
number
that's 2019 data um 145 million half of
the us is tattooed
and half of them have more than one
tattoo it's not just like one little one
off you know what i mean
so a quarter of americans have more than
one tattoo
yeah that's like the best engagement of
any product i've ever heard
i mean it's amazing and it's amazing and
it's like it's incredible to me that not
a lot of people have really tried to
harness the space
like this is a huge market it's a huge
market
it's gigantic americans are spending 1.7
billion dollars a year on tattoos
billion with a b
it's crazy um you know and i think
there's
a lot to say for the fact that it's sort
of this disjunct industry and that
there's not
a centrifying force to it right there's
not really leaders in the market because
all of these are sort of individuals
they're all individual freelancers
they're all small
businesses that you that are like the
the small shop in the corner of that
neighborhood
that you go to because you befriended
that's so interesting
how do you explain then that there is
such a big stigma around tattoos
yet half of americans have tattoos
yeah it's interesting um you know i
think people maybe get tattoos and then
you know maybe disjunct themselves from
the tattoo community right
so there's a difference between someone
that has a tattoo and someone that is
like
part of this cult if you will for lack
of a better word
you know um and you know people are very
insular about
being um allowing other people into that
sort of cult mentality right
and i think it that has a lot to do with
the fact that they
have been stigmatized and have been you
know semi you know not discriminated
against in a way that many other groups
are for many other reasons
um but you know this stigma has sort of
allowed you know heavily tattooed people
or people that are you know a lot more
heavily in the industry than you know
just having a one-off tattoo
um allows to really sort of um band
together and nearly reject
other people entering the tattoo
industry which is also something that
tattered is fighting right so
um i remember the first the first time i
went to go get a big piece
i walk into the studio and i was like uh
okay so uh i have this tattoo idea this
is
what i want um can i mean could someone
talk to me
and i got this stank eye of a lifetime
from this woman
and she was just like can you just look
up our artist
and contact the artist directly you
don't do that like
essentially like get out like wow
i didn't know it operated like that you
can't just go to a shop because
the shops are literally just chairs
essentially that they
rent out to people like you contract
with the tattoo yes
oh i had no idea i thought you walk in
and you say
oh you you you look like a great artist
come here and i want you to
to draw something on me no not for
something custom so i mean they have
like
again like you know pushing towards the
stigma but on the like
street with all the bars in any given
city there's probably a tattoo shop that
you can probably walk in and choose
something off of a laminated page in a
binder
and get that tattoo um well that is not
at all how the majority i thought it was
more like a haircut that you have a big
book of a bunch of different styles and
you can come and say i want this style
now
okay i had no idea so and that's why it
makes it forever
right so so now it makes so much more
sense to me why there needs to be
dedicated marketplace because if you're
contracting the artist
first of all it doesn't make too much
sense to me that you only have access to
the local
local artists that you're seeing a
geographical area because if you're
getting a tattoo for life
you know maybe you're willing to travel
a little bit further for that special
artist
you know five hour drive that is that
can do something very very special so so
now it makes perfect sense but please
keep going
absolutely absolutely and there's also
an issue with sort of um
the data being very disjunct right so
when you're choosing a tattoo artist
the um having all of the different data
points
available to you is actually essential
right you can't just have one
so when i say data points i mean the
artist's location right
um i would love to go and get that in
tel aviv like probably not today
um you know what i mean um so location
of the artist is essential
price range is essential because prices
can range from they usually go on hourly
rates they can range from like
a hundred dollars an hour i've seen some
for eight hundred dollars an hour
no joke like dollars an hour eight
hundred dollars an hour i have seen it i
mean these are like celebrity tattoo
artists but still
i think i'm switching profession
you should i feel like my fallback
should totally be tattoo artistry
you don't even know if this is
worthwhile
that's incredible and how many how many
hours does it usually take to get a
you know a significant tattoo yeah i
mean it can be anywhere from like
three to twelve right it really depends
on the on the size
detail on oh yeah yeah yeah these things
like the average tattoo cost is like
about twenty five hundred dollars
the average tattoo cost is twenty five
hundred dollars
yes or that's maybe the average um
amount that a
person has spent on their tattoos so
it's at least that is still
still incredible yeah yeah yeah my
tattoos were thousands
thousands you know if i'm comparing it
per second to the streaming industry
that's probably pretty much what a
person would pay for
for spotify netflix hulu
over their entire lifetime right right
so we're pretty much in the same size
okay so that's that's fascinating
talk to me a little bit about tatted and
talk to me about the challenges about
the traction what what
what insights have you gained as you've
been building this marketplace
yeah absolutely so um what we built is
essentially an intelligent search where
we're combining the ability to search by
uh location price range um
specialization right
so speaking back to sort of um you know
my history
with art um a tattoo specializes
in a way that is very um significant
whenever you're making that choice so
a tattoo artist that does uh
impressionist tattoos like you're not
comparing to fine art
doesn't do like pop art andy warhol
stuff right like that's not the same
person
in the same way if you want a tattoo
artist to do like script
tattoo or if you want a tattoo artist to
do americana you're not going to go to
someone that does
the opposite thing you know what i mean
so you need to know their specialization
actually
um so it searches by specialization and
you can even search by keyword if you
want to see a certain image so you want
to see a butterfly in their portfolio
fine you can search by a certain image
as well right
so you have all of these options right
typically what a user would have to do
is like
um go to yelp if they want to know the
location of the studio they would have
to go to instagram and go on a hashtag
of the specialization
find a great artist wait they're in
berlin like there's no cohesive data so
that's what tablet has brought together
um
the the app itself has actually gone
beautifully which is probably because i
have a history in you know
actually building type oil apps so it's
like you know that part has gone really
really smoothly and we've got an amazing
amazing responsiveness
the number one thing that i hear back is
how has this not been built before
um right after this conversation i'm
shocked myself
i i have been shocked this whole time
that i've been waiting for someone else
to do it i was like i don't even know if
i want to do this this is a little work
you guys someone else needs to do this
um and no one did and so here we are um
but i love it it's like a labor of love
and watching it sort of
gain traction and come about i mean in
the first month we had 2 000 downloads
um
we're only open in 12 launch cities the
12 most tattooed cities in the u.s
um what are some of them um
new york la austin miami denver
portland houston san diego san francisco
chicago um all the main ones that you
might imagine
um and i believe that these are also the
12 main
tech hubs of the us yeah yeah it's
funnily enough you know the urban
centers seem to follow both of those
trends for sure so that makes sense um
no but what i want to do is make sure
that there is a strong database in each
of these cities right so imagine i just
like launched
oh we're in the us um what if you're in
a richmond and like only two artists
have signed up there
like that's gonna be a horrible
experience you know what i mean and
we're gonna look at my app and say
there's no
artist on here actually like bye you
know so i was like all right we need to
concentrate in
a you know limited number of cities
build a really strong database i want
hundreds of artists like if not like a
thousand plus in each city
and then i can launch and get even more
you know what i mean i want everyone on
this app
um the the kind of you know other thing
to mention is that it's free for both
sides which no other platform has been
for artists which is
you know so horrible for them because
these artists um
you know they're trying to make a living
off of their art and it's not easy
uh they have to pay for their own health
insurance they have to be for if they're
even if they're in a studio they pay for
all their own materials
all the ink you see which is very
expensive all the machines very
expensive
um all insurances like for like you know
their actual art um
literally everything they have to
actually pay for and then a studio takes
a cut on top of that
so making a artist pay for a platform in
order to promote themselves didn't make
any
sense to me so it is actually free for
both sides and we've still figured out a
way
to monetize but that was really really
important to me just because it is a
huge mission to
empower creative industries through tech
and allow these people to not
be paycheck to paycheck for their whole
lives um so that was really important
um the other thing that you know is of
note is that as i was
as i was becoming more acquainted with
the community and this was very much a
grassroots movement right so
instead of going from the very ground up
and like you know going to the top
tattoo artists in the us and getting
them to endorse us or whatever it is
i was like all right they already have a
following okay like they already have
enough business
um i want to build this i want this to
be a grassroots movement right i want to
be real i want this to be for the people
um and that means like for us as users
but also for the tattoo artists right
so um you know we did tons of uh sort of
micro influencer outreach
we did an ambassador program where
literally i would take
30 minute calls with every single artist
that partnered with us that wanted to be
on the platform and told them about the
mission and heard about their pain
points
and all that and got all these people
sort of behind it now
as i became more and more acquainted
with the community
um and funnily enough you know as we're
building our social media presence and
um sort of defining our brand for me in
my value set
diversity and inclusion of all people
you know of every
um you know gender and race and
shape and size was always going to be a
part of this um no i thought i was going
to get sort of a nod from the tattooing
community just like yes that's what we
believe too like thank you so much like
we're all moving on um because it's a
counter culture right it's a counter
culture
and in my head that meant that it was
not subject to the white male
paradigm you know so i was like great
okay you know we're probably we probably
don't have to worry about that
that i know the more i got connected
with people they were nearly informing
me of my own mission
right and i really connected with people
they were saying thank you so
much for being such a strong voice for
the lgbtq community and tattooing
and i was like what am i am i struggling
with that i thought we were just you
know being inclusive and being diverse
and
the more and more i realized that it
actually is a huge issue
in tattoo culture which is shocking to
me personally
um but it but it is and at the end of
the day when you think about it there's
like there's no hr department for tattoo
artists
you know what i mean like if they don't
you know there's tons of stories about
women being harassed by shop owners you
know what i mean or worse
like so like there's there's no one
that's
able to police that he's able to set
these standards you know um
so todd became to be a really proactive
voice for that
nearly accidentally to be really honest
with you um and the more and more i got
the response and the more and more i had
people reach out to me saying i will
work for you for free i had creative
directors i had interns i had
i have a developer reaching out to me
that is connected to the community that
says
you know i you know i had literally
someone come to me and said i
am gay and i have never been comfortable
working or uh walking into tattoo parlor
thank you so much like i would love to
get a tattoo but i just don't even feel
comfortable
i want to work for you um so that's just
that's just remarkable
that really it was incredible and you
know it's crazy yeah
thank you thank you for this inspiration
thank you thank you for sharing this the
these stories and day and and it's
amazing how that
the side effect consequences come about
and and i'm sure that that fulfillment
of hearing these remarks uh by people
that
that haven't felt comfortable uh you
know showing their passion or
or exhibiting their their excitement or
over this industry
it's just it's really really great uh so
it's a really fantastic job on that and
then thank you for doing good for the
world
before we leave i have to ask you for
the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um the hardest question the hardest
question
i would say i would say authentic
um usually you get sort of me unfiltered
at all times um for better worse
authentic um
passionate if you didn't already notice
um i'm very passionate about everything
i do
yeah definitely definitely um an
adventurous
i would say you know i feel like i
usually am really ready to try
something new and gone on a limb and
take a risk
i love that laura thank you very very
much
uh best of luck with that today i know
it's just the beginning of a long
journey
uh but but it sounds like it's already
it's so it sounds like it's after a
great beginning so
best of luck and and i look forward to
following the journey closely
take care absolutely thank you so much